if I had 10 minutes with Barack Obama
right now I'm not sure I'd begin with a
list of issues I think sometimes our
politics is to list driven and one of
the magical touches Barack Obama brought
to the political process was not a
litany of issues it was more different
spirit of politics I would say to Barack
Obama don't close yourself off you are
the first community organizer in chief
sitting in the White House the people's
house make sure that you stay in touch
with those who work their heart and soul
out for you to get into this position
don't get closed off don't begin to live
in the bubble of Washington DC or listen
only to those who are in the
establishment however broadly defined
that is so that would be one issue and
then coming off of that I would say you
know feel the pain in this country don't
just feel the pain on Wall Street feel
the pain of those who are being evicted
across this country as you think hard
about your economic program and think
hard about what you're going to do to
really reinvigorated ISM and power of
your presence your election after eight
years of a long national nightmare but
your policies are also going to matter
so think hard for example before you
deep in a military escalation in
Afghanistan which not only might
alienate those who want to reengage
America re-engage the Obama
administration but also it may squander
the resources so desperately needed for
your project to rebuild and reinvest in
this country those would be too broad at
home and abroad issues I frame
I think pragmatism is pragmatism is an
ideology the nation's cover story three
weeks ago was about Barack Obama
pragmatist there's a long and fine
tradition John Dewey for example was a
pragmatist pragmatism has to be imbued
with principles so I don't see the end
of ideas I see the beginning of a flurry
of different kinds of ideas which may
not be in the box they may be transcend
certain lines but we are still going to
see ideological divisions it's
interesting to me because I think
ideology in this country has always been
a dirty word in other parts of you know
in Europe for example ideology it means
you know you're a set of ideas here it's
kind of subversive and dangerous of
course people of ideologies if you
believe in a more progressive taxation
system you know that's a set of ideas so
we'll see but i think you know Franklin
Delano Roosevelt a president who Barack
Obama is obviously reading and modeling
himself on as well as Abraham Lincoln
was a supreme pragmatist his idea was
constant persistent experimentation but
in that experimentation was a re
architecture of the American economic
system for example and we are living
with those ideas those models those
policies which a pragmatist Franklin
Delano Roosevelt put into place decades
ago otherwise this economic crisis would
be much more severe just in a broader
more philosophical level I'm i think
that caution is the new risky I think to
be bold at this time to be bold in
rethinking what has been done whether
it's in the economic domestic sphere or
abroad and foreign policy would be wise
I think the world is at a moment where
the old order has collapsed and that's
an ideological statement I think some of
the ideological framework of certainly
the economic deregulated system we've
lived with that's up for grabs so where
that heads will be
the part of the struggle go nuts
struggle but part of the work going
forward and again I come back to I'm
worried that Barack Obama not so much
pragmatist because I think that has a
value but that there's a caution there's
a caution and that he might be too
willing in that cautiousness to listen
to others who he thinks have greater
experience and I'm a little suspicious
of experience if it comes from long
service in government because not to
conflate those in this current
administration but let's not forget that
Dick Cheney and Donald Rumsfeld and
condi rice had lots of experience